[Musique]
bonsoir lundi 22 juin très heureux de
vous retrouver pour une nouvelle semaine
d'information locale sur tv 78 voici les
titres de ce journal protocole sanitaire
allégé pour deux semaines de classe ce
matin tous les élèves de la maternelle
au collège étaient attendus sur les
bancs de l'école
une rentrée obligatoire décrété par le
président de la république reportage à
montigny le bretonneux et saint cyr
l'école baisse de la limitation de la
vitesse sur autoroute création du crime
déco site voici quelques-unes des
propositions de la convention citoyenne
pour le climat elle s'est réunie ce
week-end parmi les 150 participants unis
blinoise interview à suivre et puis hier
c'était la fête de la musique événement
forcément particulier avec le contexte
sanitaire à part au royal des champs à
magny les hameaux les cuivres étaient de
sortie pour une déambulation musicale
dans le respect des gestes barrières à
deux semaines des vacances d'été une
rentrée des classes obligatoire les
élèves étaient attendus ce matin pour ce
retour total le premier depuis trois
mois et dans les yvelines plus de deux
cent mille enfants et adolescents sont
concernés dans les 1000 écoles
maternelles et élémentaires et les 116
collèges du territoire
alors comment s'est déroulée cette
rentrée patrick jacques de dixmude et
mathilde et demi sont allés poser la
question à l'école françois mansart de
montigny le bretonneux regardez c'est la
première journée je pense que c'est
important qu'ils reviennent un peu à
l'école même si c'est que pour deux
semaines mais pour reprendre un peu un
rythme revoir aussi des autres enfants
et qui est en contact pendant une
structure c'est assez important
ça s'est passé très bien j' avais juste
la maîtresse cavell masque
du coup on n'entendait pas très bien et
juste ça qu'il dérangeait et puis après
c'était tout qui était cool je pense que
c'est quelque chose de très bien
il faut que tous les enfants puissent
retrouver le cadre de l'école et
participer au dernier
dernier dans l'hérault revoir pour les
vacances et j'ai retrouvé plein d'amis
et c'est super content de retrouver
l'école et après et j'ai joué à cha cha
ombre c'était bien
c'est bien pour lui d'avoir entre
l'école je pense qui est au bout de
trois mois ont finement là ça commence à
peser lourd et on a voulu le rhum et à
l'école et ce retour en classe dans un
format quasi normale a été rendue
possible par l'allègement du protocole
sanitaire qui était très stricte dans sa
première version
reportage à l'école élémentaire romain
rolland de saint cyr l'école avec
aurélie ans après trois semaines d'école
à la maison pour certains tous les
élèves ont pu retrouver leurs salles de
classe
depuis le déconfinement en raison d'un
protocole sanitaires strictes seuls 200
écoliers sur les 366 inscrits fréquenté
chaque semaine l'école romain rolland de
saint cyr l'école
désormais tout le monde peut être
accueillis en continuant malgré tout à
respecter quelques gestes barrières
chaque classe a un espace pour prendre
les récréations dans les classes on a
rajouté des tables comme on a pu pour
pouvoir garder un maximum de distance
entre les élèves
ça n'a pas toujours été possible donc il
n'ya pas toujours un mètres d'écart
entre chaque élève quand ils sont assis
dans la classe il se lave toujours les
mains en rentrant en classe en sortant
récréation en rentrant de récréation
avant de manger à la cantine
toutes les écoles élémentaires de saint
cyr l'école propose un service de
restauration le midi ainsi que le centre
de loisirs le soir une organisation
rendue possible grâce à la municipalité
la commune fournit jallet
hydroalcoolique savons antibactériens
aux logiques sur les
des toilettes et puis tous les
aménagements nécessaires qui sont les
traçages au sol dans la cour dans les
couloirs de façon à pouvoir permettre la
distanciation ce matin cette classe de
cm2 comptait seulement un absent alors
que les grandes vacances débutent dans
moins de deux semaines l'éducation
nationale met en avant plusieurs
intérêts pédagogiques pour cette reprise
pour tous symboliquement
psychologiquement c'était important à la
fois de reprendre cette dynamique
globale on va dire normal de d'une
pédagogie de classe entière
et puis de marquer cette transition
finalement avec avant l'été pour pouvoir
s'imaginer se projeter déjà dans la
classe du niveau supérieur l'année
prochaine je pense qu'il faut apprendre
à vivre avec les avec le co vide comme
plein d'autres maladies qui circulent
plein d'autres virus dans 7
établissements scolaires près de 90 %
des élèves sont retournés en classe ce
22 juin
la rentrée des classes donc dans un
contexte de recul de l'épidémie de kovy
19 même si le virus est toujours présent
dans les yvelines deux décès
supplémentaires ont été recensés durant
le week end à l'hôpital portant à 513 le
nombre de victimes aux derniers chiffres
communiqués par la rs4 145 patients
étaient hospitalisés hier dimanche soit
neuf ans - entre vendredi et dimanche
même si en même temps on a enregistré
six nouvelles hospitalisations dans le
département le nombre de personnes en
réanimation a légèrement reculé pendant
le week-end 24 patients étaient encore
concernés hier et depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire 2058 personnes ont été
guéries de lakovic 19 après un passage à
l'hôpital dans l'actualité également les
conclusions de la convention citoyenne
pour le climat les participants ont
remis hier leurs propositions au
gouvernement après deux jours de vote et
de discussions au conseil économique
social et environnemental
parmi eux une yvelinoise interrogé par
manon varalda elle les 150 citoyens
tirés au sort pour proposer des mesures
de lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique ont voté ce week-end emmanuel
macron avait décidé d'organiser un
exercice de démocratie participative
inédit en france après la crise des
gilet jaune est déclenchée par l'annoncé
d'une taxe carbone sur les carburants
annie pata bonjour bonjour vous habitez
saint quentin en yvelines et vous étiez
parmi les 150 citoyens tirés au sort
pour trouver des solutions de manière à
réduire d'au moins 40% d'ici 2030 les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
comment avez vous vécu ces réunions vous
étiez dans le groupe produit aller
travailler effectivement donc 7
comme vous l'avez très bien dit cette
initiation venons de mouvement le gilet
citoyen de gilet jaune et qui a été donc
validé par le gouvernement a vu donc
naître la convention citoyenne qui a
débuté le 4 octobre 2019
c'est une expérience très riche et c'est
une fierté d'avoir pu à participer sur
la convention citoyenne pour le krill a
vraiment et la finalité de toutes ces
réunions après ce week-end notamment ces
échanges c'est vote quel est le bilan
que vous dressez au lendemain de ces
échanges
le bilan donc vous l'avez dit on a
travaillé en groupes thématiques il y
avait cinq groupes thématiques je fais
partie du groupe produire et travailler
il y avait également le groupe se loger
se nourrir
consommer et se déplacer sur la finalité
de la session 7 qui vient de se finir ce
week end
on a donc adopté les propositions de
mesures qui d'emporter un consensus au
sein des 150 citoyens et pour la
majorité des propositions ont été votés
par ce large consensus en donc
maintenant à ses propositions au vont
aller dans les bars de l'exécutif et des
parlementaires sauf deux propositions
qu'on a demandé à soumettre au
référendum
parmi vos mesures dans votre rapport de
600 pages
la réduction de la vitesse sur autoroute
de 130 km heure à 110 km heure vous
n'avez pas peur que cela déclenche une
polémique comme précédent
avec la limitation des 80 km heure sur
les routes secondaires
alors oui on a bien on a bien vu que sa
porte est justement débat dans l'opinion
publique
et c'était aussi l'objectif ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que notre lettre
demande à vous l'avez très bien rappelé
était de réduire d'au moins 40% les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
sachant qu'aujourd'hui la commission
européenne et même plus ambitieuse en
demandant dans l'allier entre 55 à 65 %
de réduction il faut savoir que se
déplacer représente est très forte part
de nos émissions de gaz à effet de serre
et réduire de 130 à 110
on a travaillé avec les experts qu'on a
auditionné et ça c'est pas fait comme
cela réduit effectivement de manière
significative la réduction de nos gaz à
effet de serre donc quand on veut être
aussi dans cet objectif à des accords de
paris il faut aussi voir là où on peut
réduire réellement nos émissions de gaz
à effet de serre une autre de vos
propositions adopté une loi créant le
crime d' écocide afin de sanctionner une
atteinte grave à l'environnement
pourtant des propositions de loi pour
l'introduction de l'écocide dans le
droit pénal français ont été rejetés
cette année au sénat et à l'assemblée
nationale
qu'attendez vous alors c'est vrai c'est
principalement l'introduction des
limites planétaires aujourd'hui qu'ils
ne font pas consensus dans le milieu
juridique ca et pourtant c'est c'est
nécessaire pour notre protection de la
biodiversité nos écosystèmes
alors ce qu'on a voulu à travers ces
propositions qui pratiquement une
proposition de loi c'est qu'on l'a fait
partir sur la voie référendaire donc bon
le demandent à ce que sa portée au
référendum pour que les français
puissent se saisir de cette question les
limites planétaires qu'est-ce que si
elles se sont simplement des indicateurs
on va nous permettre de savoir à quel
niveau on a dépassé un certain seuil qui
nous permet de savoir si on est encore
dans une acceptabilité du respect de
notre biodiversité nos écosystèmes
donc il va falloir à travers sur l'effet
random on puisse nous communiquer qu'on
puisse avoir cette campagne
d'information auprès des français mais
sachez que c'est
un des thèmes qui est porté par la
convention et qui peut qui peut aller
loin si les français nous suivre quelle
peine souhaitez vous quelle peine qu'on
terme de sanction oui en terme de
sanction alors dont la proposition il a
été demandé une la création de ce qu'on
appelle une haute autorité comme une
commission à judiciaires injustement qui
va permettre de suivre toutes toutes les
demandes liées
voilà au non respect au non-respect de
ces crimes
entre parenthèses négocier donc les
possibles c'est le crime lié à l'autre
écosystèmes la biodiversité et la
convention citoyenne pour le climat a
réfuté une mesure à la réduction du
temps de travail à quatre jours par
semaine soit 28 heures hebdomadaires
cette mesure a été rejetée 65% par les
150 membres de la convention pourquoi
avoir rejeté cette mesure par rapport à
la crise sanitaire et donc à la crise
économique actuelle
alors oui on savait que ça ne faisait
pas consensus au sein des 150 citoyens
ils étaient tout de même important que
ce sujet soit ni à l'ordre du jour dans
le débat de la convention on ne pouvait
pas passer à côté
j'ai fait partie des citoyennes qui ont
défendu les ventes 8 heures comme je
l'aï dit plusieurs économistes y croire
et propose même cette solution dans le
contexte de crise plusieurs pays même en
europe et en a aujourd'hui propose
également c'est un ajustement du temps
de travail
alors pourquoi les citoyens ont eu peur
ils se sont dit c'est pas le moment
par rapport au contexte ils se sont dit
ça va être mal accueillie par parler
français donc ils ont préféré à rejeter
sachant que la proposition était quand
même de donner une alternative jusqu'en
2030 ça veut dire que dans un horizon de
10 ans permettre cette cette mise en
place et ce n'était pas une obligation
est vraiment d'accord en accord avec les
branches d'entreprise les accords
d'entreprise permettent aux sociétés qui
le pouvaient et qui le souhaitait a de
pouvoir mettre en place ce dispositif
après l'aveu après tous ces échanges
quelle est la suite attendue
qu'espérez-vous
alors là on déjà ce soir on a de nouveau
rendez vous avec madame elisabeth bornes
qui nous a rendu visite hier pour la
remise de notre rapport final donc ça va
être un premier échange pour justement
précisé un peu plus les ambitions et les
objectifs nous sommes invités à le
partner par le président à l'elysée donc
les 150 sont donc conviés à l'elysée
mais la suite de cela qu on vous l'avait
très bien compris nos propositions ont
conquis su-33 voit donc la voie
législative à la voie réglementaire ou
la voie référendaire
mais ce qu'on veut vraiment c'est qu'on
était 150 à travailler comme je le dis
souvent 150 visage et on veut vraiment
que tous les citoyens français se
saisissent de ces propositions
que ce soit au niveau du gouvernement
n'est ce soit des organisations des ong
des militants mais des citoyens lambda
on me sollicite beaucoup en ce moment et
j'entends beaucoup d'initiatives qui
souhaitent intégrer le citoyen dans les
prises de décision dans la participation
délibérative et ça pour moi c'est une
victoire de la convention citoyenne et
comme vous l'avez dit pour rappel le
président de la république doit recevoir
les membres de la convention le 29 ans
pour apporter les premières réponses en
attendant annie pata et d'autres
participants de cette convention
citoyenne pour le climat sont reçus ce
lundi soir par la ministre de la
transition écologique et solidaire
elisabeth bornes
[Musique]
il agit moins six le second tour des
élections municipales c'est dimanche
prochain le scrutin concerne encore 45
communes dans les yvelines
et d'ici le 28 juin zone sur les
candidats s'engagent et attrapes ils
sont 3 dont le maire sortant guy
malandain en lice pour un quatrième
mandat
au premier tour il s'est classé
troisième avec sa liste pour trappe la
gauche qui agit nous lui avons donné
deux minutes pour vous convaincre
[Musique]
une équipe qui est avec moi autour de
moi mais et est engagée pour la ville de
trappes et les habitantes trappe avec
une passion est évidente et nomma pour
un parcours de carrière politique
et puis un apport de personnalités dont
les compétences sont des compétences
associées hâtez-vous les compétences
professionnelles qui se sont ajoutés
j'allais dire aux anciens entre
guillemets l'humain et et l'urd 1 parce
que les deux les deux vont ensemble
donc ce qui concerne l'humain la
solidarité et la culture l'autre aspect
c'est celle urbain il nous reste deux
j'allais dire de trois problèmes
essentiels quoi le problème essentiel
c'est conduire et la réalisation du
plateau urbain dont les travaux sont
commencés maintenant et ça va durer
trois ans deuxième axe c'est l'éco
quartier camp de fer à la halle
freyssinet à l'entrée de trappes là-bas
ou siens en dépôt de tout et n'importe
quoi
et puis il ya le troisième pôle une
ambulance
c'est tout quartier dia donner donner un
temps de vacances de qualité mais aussi
de plaisir de partage depuis les petits
ponts zafar et les petits enfants
jusqu'aux jusqu'aux seniors ce projet
est prêt il faut appuyer maintenant
comme on dit c'est facile sur le bouton
on a vraiment marché et et diyala
trois candidats également du côté de la
verrière dont le premier adjoint de la
commune jean yves blé sa liste ensemble
à verrières citoyenne est arrivé en
troisième position le 15 mars dernier
présentation aussi en deux minutes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le point fort de notre liste et une
liste équilibrée diverses qui s'appuie à
la fois sur une génération de nouveaux
mais aussi d'anciens d'anciens élus dont
des anciens des adjoints actuellement
elle est ici des différents quartiers
elle s'est construite au fil de l'eau on
a rencontré un certain nombre de nos
colistiers au en porte à porte et qui
sont qui leur ont donné leur aval et
leur consentement à intégrer notre liste
[Applaudissements]
le développement du quartier gare bécane
parce que c'est lui qui nous apportera
un second souffle
c'est lui qui nous permettra de relancer
notre activité économique et de sortir
de l'ornière et de la prise de con est
enfermé avec les subsides de l'état
puisque on est un peu sous perfusion en
permanence sur cette commune dont il
faut donner une nouvelle impulsion à
celle ci et cela passe bien évidemment
par le projet guère buccale qui est
aussi en lien avec celui du bois de les
tempes
[Applaudissements]
elle sera à la fois d'aller trouver le
président de sky 1 pour discuter et pour
mettre en oeuvre rapidement le chantier
gharbi cannes mais ça sera aussi d'aller
trouver l'inspection académique pour
leur dire nous étions convention
académique de priorité éducative
vous nous avez sorti on a demandé
maintes et maintes fois y rester parce
que pour nous c'est nécessaire et c'est
important pour notre population c'est
important pour nos enfants et nous quand
nous irons voir l'inspection pour
demander à être de nouveau dans ce
dispositif d'accompagnement qui permet à
la fois aux enseignants d'avoir des
moyens supplémentaires et 10 ans aux
enfants d'en bénéficier
[Applaudissements]
et pour être complet sur cette page
municipal suite ce soir de nos débats en
vue du second tour du scrutin ce lundi
soir à 20h c'est avec les candidats de
la commune de villepreux débat à avoir
sur tv 78 et à écouter aussi sur les
ondes de radio sensations et une
fréquence 98 points 4
[Musique]
l'actualité de ce lundi 22 juin c'est
aussi la réouverture des cinémas les
amateurs de septième art était au rendez
vous pour voir un film en salles après
trois mois de fermeture et ce sont des
cinéphiles ravi qu'on retrouvait patrick
jacques de dixmude et mathilde et demi à
l'espace philippe noiret des clayes sous
bois et aussi à l'ugc skywest de
montigny le bretonneux
qu'est ce que j'ai envie d'aller au
cinéma tout simplement parce que je suis
nul je suis une signifie jeu et donc
j'avais envie de revenir j'en ai je veux
dire gg
j'ai confinés comme tout le monde
quelque part savoir que début d'une vie
à peu près normale
voilà mais bon on est content que la vie
reprenne en fait un hasard aujourd'hui
j'avais envie de venir au cinéma donc
j'ai suivi ça m'a manqué moi le grand
écran je viens souvent au cinéma je
viens plusieurs fois par semaine en
principe il ya toute l'ambiance mon nom
n'était pas très nombreux dans la salle
mais pour certains films il ya aussi
l'ambiance qui fait qu'en toute la salle
vibre avec des émotions c'est très
important pour moi j'ai besoin de
gestion d'une ressource et en allant
voir dessiner j'ai besoin de découvrir
des films c'est un divertissement
je suis abonné je suis j'habite à
plaisir je suis abonné à ce cinéma
depuis un certain temps et est quand
j'ai su que ça allait ouvrir ta b
j'étais parmi les trois premiers j'étais
la première à arriver dans la salle
parce que je souhaitais vivement voir ce
film et puis sortie redécouvrir le
cinéma le ce dimanche c'était la fête de
la musique beaucoup d'annulations dans
les communes mais aussi des animations
maintenu les yvelinois ont pu par
exemple profiter et des extérieurs de
l'abbaye port royal des champs à magny
les hameaux pour respecter les règles
sanitaires une déambulation au son des
cuivres étaient proposés dans les
jardins de nouveaux mathilde et demi et
patrick jacques de dixmude 1 dans les
jardins de port royal les cuivres
résonne pour la fête de la musique
les familles se sont réunis dans les
jardins de l'abbaye pour célébrer cette
fête malgré les règles sanitaires à
respecter je crois qu'on a été privé
suffisamment longtemps de concert et
c'est une très bonne idée de force à
l'extérieur
le fait de venir à la campagne s'asseoir
dans l'herbe ça fait du bien quand même
c'est quand même une liberté on retrouve
sa liberté de bah voilà de profiter des
bons moments et il la musique en est une
c'est formidable c'est c'est quand même
la base de beaucoup de choses aux
musiques qui ont été confinés donc
effectivement on peut profiter en plus
on est en plein air donc pas de masque
pas de rien on est tranquille
les visiteurs ont pu déambuler tout en
appréciant les morceaux proposés par
l'ensemble couleur cuivre qui souhaitait
à nouveau ensemble depuis le confinement
il a fallu pour ce conte près en vente
et la musique pour pouvoir jouer en
extérieur
là ça va être une première pour nous de
jouer dehors j'espère que le temps va
tenir et
de façon à ce que ce soit festif pour
l'ouverture du musée pour le retour à la
musique au public surtout qui nous a
beaucoup manqué pendant quatre mois
on a dû continuer à s'entraîner à jouer
et c'est jamais facile quand on n'a pas
de projections sur le long terme mais on
est très très très content d'être là
aujourd'hui le musée port royal des
champs a profité de la fête de la
musique pour ouvrir ses portes qui a été
réaménagé à l'occasion pour maintenir la
distanciation physique
aujourd'hui ça reste compliqué de faire
des manifestations dans des endroits
fermés et confiné ce qui veut dire que
faire de la musique en plein air d'abord
c'est l'esprit de la fête de la musique
et que du coup les règles bien sûr
existent mais elles sont plus faciles à
observer c'est à dire que en jouant
dehors on demande bien sûr au public de
garder des distance raisonnable de faire
effectivement attention mais on n'a pas
les contraintes d'une salle de spectacle
port royal des champs va accueillir cet
été des groupes et orchestres pour
permettre aux visiteurs d'écouter de la
musique en extérieur tous les samedis
soirs une découverte musicale avec le
rappeur la plume à cet artiste
indépendant originaire de mantes la
jolie et vite aujourd'hui à asher hill a
profité du confinement pour travailler
sur son troisième album
l'occasion également de mettre en image
son morceau changer le monde issu de son
deuxième ep et qui a correspondaient
parfaitement avec la situation actuelle
les propos sont recueillis par aurélien
le conte finances prêtait vraiment bien
mettre en valeur ce morceau ce que voilà
laissez moi faire il vous pose dans ce
monde hostile faire fleurir des roses
presque s'en est fini c c'était vraiment
ce qu'on était en train de vivre à
l'hédonisme à dire une petite pause
d'espoir et en même temps on était seuls
tous chacun chez shehu et j'ai eu l'idée
de concevoir la 2de le clip et on
demande en a trouvé personne que les
prêter au jeu que je connaissais bien
donner des images d'elle même avec le
redoux et envoyer leurs
que ce contrôle des masses qui ont fait
rouler que c'est la vérité tu sais peu
de gens y ont accès c'est un morceau qui
eux étaient comment dire qui a été
effectué avec un groupe de gospel et
blues gospel choir
ils m'ont apporté beaucoup de force ils
sont venus chanter un refrain que
j'avais écrit et noir coule à la
puissance que moi j'aurais pas pu
apporter sigefi ci avait été tout seul à
le chanter il défendre des causes justes
avec lui quelques rimes
aiguisé ma prose pour voir les
consciences qui s'illumine la pl omaha
[Musique]
direction d'avron pour la fin de ce
journal avec cette idée de sortie pour
les vacances d'été pourquoi pas le
domaine la bouche du roy ex winery et
parisienne va inaugurer et des circuits
oenologiques et ce à partir du 26 juin
il sera possible de passer deux heures
dans les vignes avec dégustation à la
clé et bien sûr avec modération le
reportage de mickaël millero visiter un
domaine viticole dans les mines sera
désormais possible la bouche du roi
premier professionnel de la plaine de
versailles va inaugurer des circuits
oenologique à partir du 26 juin le site
implanté depuis 2010 est dans le
département proposera quatre à cinq
créneaux par semaine
c'était très important pour nous de
parler notre projet est d'allier le
tourisme est de pouvoir expliquer notre
travail deux heures d'immersion on vous
amène dans les vignes en partant du
village qui ont fini par une dégustation
au centre du vignoble avant de vous
ramener qui qui vous permettront au bout
de deux heures d'être rentré dans
l'histoire de la bouche du roi qui est
très riche dans la plaine de versailles
et de connaître vraiment tout sur nova
les visiteurs pourront notamment
découvrir les six cépages du domaine
répartis sur 23 hectares
les guides présenteront également
l'histoire du sol argilo-calcaire les
dernières plantations du mois de juin
sur le site
ce circuit sur cette commune de 340
habitants est apprécié des élus locaux
je trouve que ça va amener un peu du
qualitatif au village et notamment un
peu de
ça peut faire connaître un peu ce
village qui est en beau village les
yvelines et ça va montrer combien ce
département se sont créés dans l'âtre
dans la tradition on est un vieux
département à l'école mais aussi dans la
modernité dans l'avenir ces découvertes
coûtera 39 euros les responsables
espèrent attirer cet été entre 50 et 60
personnes par semaine sur ce domaine qui
devrait produire plus de cent cinquante
mille bouteilles dès 2024
enfin autre idée pour vous aérer vous
pourrez leur rendre visite cet été aux
au safari de thoiry et de gori mallié
bas et ayo sont arrivés sur place la
semaine dernière avant d'être présenté
au public une phase d'adaptation et de
confinement est nécessaire ils seront
bientôt rejoints par deux autres mâles
une arrivée qui s'inscrit dans un vaste
programme de conservation des espèces
menacées
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de l'avoir suivi très belle soirée sur
tv 78
[Musique]